the ability to take one for all is
something that is not meant to be
possible in the world of major academia
in chapter 59 of the manga all might
explicitly said to deku
that one thrall could not be taken by
force and it can only be transferred
when the user wants it to happen
despite this events in the hero's rising
movie
coupled with what's currently going on
in the manga right now it all leads me
to believe that it's possible
this rule doesn't really matter anymore
as a warning this video will contain
spoilers from the manga to provide
evidence for what i'm saying
so do watch at your own risk if you're
an anime only also a quick announcement
my first ever q a will be happening on
this channel next week
so if you want me to answer your
questions or theories then head on over
to my patreon
and you can leave any questions you have
in the comments of my latest posts
because this is the first one ever i'll
be answering at least two questions from
any person who submits them
so be sure to get your questions in but
with that said let's get into the video
for those of you who are confused as to
why one floor can't be stolen
there's actually a pretty simple reason
as we know one fall is not a naturally
occurring quirk
but rather it's the combination of a
power stockpiling quirk
and a transfer ability the original
transfer quirk belonged to all for one's
brother
and the nature of it was such that in
order to transfer quirks
the user had to pass on some dna whether
it be hair or blood or whatever else you
can think of
crucially though the person transferring
had to want the transfer to happen
otherwise you can literally just sneak
up on deku whilst he's sleeping and then
eat a strand of his hair
and steal one for all because of this
defense mechanism
ulf one himself was never able to
acquire the quirk despite encountering
all the different users throughout
history as a side note
we've seen how people in the same
families can have similar quirks
so it's no surprise that all for one you
know he's a guy who can both steal
quirks and transfer quirks
it's no surprise that he had a brother
with just a transferring ability
too bad they didn't have any other
relatives because that family line could
have been super op
by this point back to the main point
though the first on-screen hint that we
got that one floor could be stolen
was during the heroes rising movie and
spoiler alert for those of you who
haven't seen it yet
during a scene in the woods nine used
the power of all for one
to try and steal one for all giving us
our first bit of evidence regarding the
topic of this video
for those that don't know nine was given
a duplicate version of author one
and had the capacity to steal a maximum
of eight additional quirks
as nine begins to absorb one for all
deku thinks to himself that it's about
to be stolen
which is not the thought process of
someone who has confidence
in all might's words that it couldn't be
taken by force we then see the vestiges
briefly appear
and nine is then prevented from
acquiring the power and when i first saw
this moment i assumed
that this was the safety mechanism of
one floor kicking in and you know not
allowing someone to take it away
without consent however because nine can
only steal eight quirks
he realizes that the reason he couldn't
take it was because
one fall has multiple quirks stored
inside it from all the previous users
this includes blackwhip float and
several others that we haven't seen yet
as of recording this video and remember
this guys
nine had a scanning quote that allowed
him to determine people's abilities
and he had already scanned deku prior to
you know trying to steal one for all
when he did this examination he saw
nothing about any additional quirks
the only reason he realized that deku
had more quirks stored up inside him
was because nine's own body physically
could not handle them
if the reason he couldn't take it was
because the defense of 1-4 prevented him
from doing so
then there's literally no reason why he
would know that information i mean it's
not like the quirk was actually
transferring to him in that scenario
so how would he know i mean he scanned
deku didn't see the additional quirks
and yeah it just it just wouldn't make
any sense that lets us know
that he was actually telling the truth
in this moment when he says the only
thing preventing him from acquiring the
power was the lack of space within his
own body
as you would expect harakoshi was
supervising the creation of this movie
so this hint that 14 can be stolen it
wasn't exactly left in there by accident
or anything like he would
he would have been very much aware of
what this scene is implying
and yet it was still kept in the movie
when we look in the manga
there is even more material to support
the idea that it can be stolen and it
actually ties into heroes rising as well
firstly shiguraki's upgrades at the
hands of dr garaki has leveled him up in
every conceivable way
not only does he now have all for one
but his basic level of strength like
without any quirks
is comparable to all might his decay
quirk was also upgraded pretty
substantially
giving him new abilities that might be
easy to miss but for example he can
decay the ground in a controlled way
and avoid destroying certain things like
this army of nomus for example
if you want to know more details about
how degay has improved then i broke that
down in a different video
which is in the description below these
upgrades show us for the first time
that the doctor is able to modify and
improve individual quirks
and allow the user to surpass the limits
that were previously in place
this is important because on top of
upgrading shiguraki's body and his decay
quirk
garaki obviously like i said he gave him
the original power of all for one
given that decay was upgraded in several
ways then of course the same would apply
to all for one i mean why wouldn't it
shigaraki is dr garaki's masterpiece
he's the pinnacle of over a hundred
years of quirk research
so yeah of course he's getting all the
upgrades that are available to him
before zhigi's operation the doctor
specifically said that once it was over
even one floor would be within his grasp
and at the time we didn't have any
context for what that meant
but now that we've seen the way that
decay has improved it's clear that the
manga was trying to tell us
that all for one is now also at a level
where it can surpass the defenses
of one for all this theory of mine has
even more evidence
when we consider that nine himself was
genuinely just a test run for shigaraki
like the sole reason this guy was given
off one was to just test things out the
doctor even said it himself
everything was for sugaraki and when
nine received this quirk
shiggy and afo were casually just in the
other room watching
because nine was a guinea pig it's
possible the reason he was capable of
stealing one for all you know i mean he
wasn't able to do it because of his
own personal body and issues but it did
seem he had the capability to take the
quirk
and perhaps this is due to him having a
slightly tinkered version
of all for one similar to the version
that shigaraki would eventually get
also once shigaraki received all for one
the consciousness of
afo himself was commanding him to go and
steal one for all
in my opinion it would be pretty
pointless for the voice to tell him to
get the quirk
if he wasn't actually capable of
stealing it and i also think it's pretty
unlikely that deku would
ever willingly give the power over to a
villain in fact i'm pretty sure he'd
rather die than do that
so the reason afo is commanding
shiguraki to get one for all
is because he is confident that it can
be taken away by force
if all of that is still not enough to
convince you that the game has now
completely changed
i have a few more comments to make gran
torino is someone who has known
three different generations of 1 4 users
not to mention he's been involved with
at least three different battles with
afo himself
most recently he fought afo at kamino
and during that battle he said
that afo's quirks were different from
the last time meaning that he was also
involved during ormitz battle six years
ago
and of course on top of that he was
there way back in the day when afo
killed his friend
nana shimura with all that experience
with all for one and one for all
it goes without saying that of course he
knows about the rule that 1 4 can't be
taken away right
with that being the case why is it that
in the manga
gran tuino tells deku to stay back
because he's worried
about the possibility of it being stolen
similar to what i mentioned earlier
about the hero's rising movie
this is a person who's aware of the rule
it can't be taken
but yet seemingly either forgets about
it or just straight up doesn't even
mention it when it would be relevant to
do so
taking that at face value you could
argue that maybe harakoshi regrets
establishing the precedent that 1 4
can't be stolen
and perhaps these are just you know
subtle hints to let the audience know
that it's something he wants to gloss
over and just forget about
let's just be real like if you think 14
can't be stolen
why are you even worried about that you
should be more concerned about deku's
safety
rather than one fraud as a quirk being
taken anyway
to recap so far it is highly likely that
shiguraki's
new quirk upgrades have leveled up all
for one in such a way
that it can bypass the defenses of one
for all and steal it
on top of that in situations when it
would have been relevant
both deku and gran torino have seemingly
forgotten that one floor can't be stolen
anyway which is maybe horikoshi trying
to tell us to forget about what we saw
in chapter 59.
other possibilities i didn't mention
include the fact that shiguraki might be
able to use all for one in such a way
that it lets him extract the stockpiling
quirk from one fraud
the reason all mike was confident it
couldn't be taken away was due to the
effect of the transfer quirk
it was the transfer ability that
prevented one for all from being taken
due to its established rules
but if shiguraki was able to somehow
take only the stockpiling ability from
one for all
that would allow him to bypass the
transfer quirk's defenses because he
wouldn't be taking the whole quirk
on the rare chance that this does
actually happen one flaw would still
exist in some form inside deku
as he'd retain the quirks from all the
previous users such as blackwhip for
example
it's just that the stockpiling power
would be lost alternatively
as unlikely as it sounds maybe the
reason that dr garaki and afo
were so confident that shiggy could
steal one for all is because he has some
kind of quirk stocked up inside him
that allows him to alter the will of
individuals
a quirk like this would be the easiest
way to trick deku into passing on the
quirk
if indeed one fall actually cannot be
stolen still but to be honest shigaraki
doesn't need a quirk like this i mean
he's already strong enough
so uh yeah i'm gonna hope this doesn't
happen let me know what you guys think
down below
are you of the opinion that the quirk
can be taken or are you still of the
belief that harukoshi is sticking to
what he said
about stealing one for all being
impossible the patreon q a on my channel
is coming next week probably next week
sunday
so do be sure to submit your questions
on patreon if you're interested in that
peace out